The Story Behind MONOPOLY Pieces
What do a thimble, a sack of money, a battleship,
and a top hat have in common?
Not much, other than that they are among the
playing tokens you receive in a standard Monopoly
set.
And don’t forget the wheelbarrow, which
you’ll need to carry all that cash you are
going to appropriate from your hapless opponents.
The history of Monopoly is fraught with controversy
and contention, for it seems that its inventor,
Charles Darrow, at the very least borrowed
liberally from two already existing games
when he first marketed Monopoly in the early
1930s.
After Darrow self-published the game to great
success, Parker Brothers bought the rights
to Monopoly in 1934.
While the early history is contentious, on
one thing all Monopoly historians can agree-
when Parker Brothers introduced the game in
1935, Monopoly had no player pieces and the
rules instructed the players to use such items
as buttons or pennies as player markers.
Soon thereafter, in the 1935-36 sets, Parker
Brothers included wooden player pieces shaped
like chess pawns… boring.
The first significant development in customizing
the playing pieces came in 1937, when Parker
Brothers introduced these die-cast metal tokens:
a car, flatiron, lantern, thimble, shoe, top
hat, and rocking horse.
Later that same year, a battleship and cannon
were added to raise the number of tokens to
ten.
All was quiet on the token front until 1942
when metal shortages during World War II resulted
in a comeback of wooden tokens.
But the same mix of tokens remained until
the early 1950s when the lantern, purse, and
rocking horse were kicked out in favor of
the dog, the horse & rider, and the wheelbarrow.
Parker Brothers conducted a poll to determine
what Monopoly fans would prefer for the eleventh
token; true to the spirit of the game, the
winner was a sack of money.
Parker Brothers themselves are not able to
tell us why, within a couple of years, Monopoly
went from having no tokens, to boring ones,
to idiosyncratic metal ones.
However, Ken Koury, a lawyer in L.A. who has
been a Monopoly champion and coach of the
official U.S. Team (yes, there is one) in
worldwide competition, says:
“Monopoly’s game pieces are certainly
unique and a charming part of the play.
I have heard the story that the original pieces
were actually struck from the models used
for Cracker Jack prizes.”
Not a definite answer and certainly doesn’t
instill a lot of confidence as to the accuracy.
But, it turns out, the theory is a very good
one with significant evidence to back it,
if we dig a little deeper.
Author and game expert John Chaneski, who
used to work at Game Show (a terrific game
and toy emporium in Greenwich Village), had
this to say on the subject:
“When Monopoly was first created in the
early 1930s, there were no pieces like we
know them, so they went to Cracker Jack, which
at the time was offering tiny metal tchotchkes,
like cars.
They used the same molds to make the Monopoly
pieces.
Game Show sells some antique Cracker Jack
prizes and, sure enough, the toy car is exactly
the same as the Monopoly car.
In fact, there’s also a candlestick, which
seems to be the model for the one in Clue.”
John even has a theory why the specific player
tokens were chosen:
“I think they chose Cracker Jack prizes
that symbolize wealth and poverty.
The car, top hat, and dog (especially a little
terrier like Asta, then famous from “The
Thin Man” movie series) were all possessions
of the wealthy.
The thimble, wheelbarrow, old shoe, and iron
were possessions or tools of the poor.”